- Ayo, what's up? It's J.I.D. again,
and I'm here with B/R Gridiron.
- Hey y'all, it's Sally Sossa.
- What's up? This Swae Lee.
I'm with Madden right now. We're playing
"Draft, Burner or Tweet."
Tom Brady is gonna
be in the Super Bowl.
But, you know, he has
just so many new players,
like, you never know how it's gonna go.
You know what I'm saying? So many dope players. Like, I'll
probably tweet that off a burner account so
I don't regret it later.
- I would leave it in my drafts that Tom
will win his eighth Super Bowl.
Cuz, I don't know, there's too much
young talent coming up, like, I don't know.
- Whenever you see Tom
Brady in the Super Bowl,
if he don't win, it's somethin’ goin’ on,
cuz he winnin’ the Super Bowl.
If you play against Tom Brady, whatever team he on,
just know you gonna have to work.
You got to work.
- Tom Brady will win his eighth Super Bowl ring.
I'll tweet that from my main account
cuz I definitely believe
Tom Brady, he the G.O.A.T.
I believe that.
- I'mma put that on my burner.
-Yeah, you gotta put that on the burner, though.
I don’t know.
- Tom Brady's making it.
Gonna win another championship,
goin’ on my burner account.
- You trade him, it's mad dumb to me.
- Fa sho.
- Tom Brady gonna win another Super Bowl.
I'mma put it in my drafts.
- Yeah, I'd probably put it in my drafts, too.
- Tom Brady winning another Super Bowl,
man. I'll tweet that.
- I'm drafting that.
Patrick Mahomes the best QB ever?
I'm definitely drafting that.
- Tennessee Titans gonna go undefeated.
I'mma put it on my official account.
- I would keep the Chiefs in my drafts about
going undefeated this season.
- Trevor Lawrence will win Rookie of the Year.
I'll tweet that from my main account.
I can believe that. I can see it.
- Lamar Jackson is the best—is the most
exciting player to play with in Madden.
I gotta get on the sticks, man!
I gotta get on the sticks.
I gotta play with every team.
I gotta play with everybody
so I learn all the players.
So I'mma leave that in the drafts.
- I'm drafting that.
I'm drafting Lamar Jackson is the best player in Madden.
- He ain’t, he ain't what Mike Vick was on '04.
- Lamar Jackson is the best player to use.
I'mma put it on my real account.
- I'm definitely tweeting OBJ gonna have
a bounce-back season.
OK, let's go, OBJ.
- OBJ will have a bounce-back season.
I'm tweeting that cuz that's what about to happen.
Yes, sir. OBJ about to come get crazy.
He about to come get crazy.
- OBJ will have a bounce-back season.
I'll tweet that from my main account.
- My boy Odell is the G.O.A.T.,
you know what I'm sayin’? Like,
he's still here.
He never went nowhere, you know what I'm saying?
I'd tweet that for sure. Actually, no, I wouldn't tweet that.
I would tweet, "OBJ on his G.O.A.T. s--t."
- I'm tweeting that.
- You gotta tweet that.
Yeah, bounce back, OBJ. That's my dawg.
- Fa sho. I f--k with OBJ.
- Nah, man. OBJ never left, man.
He's still the same him.
- From a burner account, I would say that
Rob Gronkowski cannot win it without Tom Brady.
- [Laughing]
Tom Brady is faster than Lamar Jackson.
You don't draft, you don't tweet, and you
don't burner that. You don't even write that.
It's not true. It’s not true.
- Jameis will carry the Saints to the playoffs.
I'll tweet that from my burner account.
- I gotta go ahead and draft—I'm drafting that.
- Chiefs goin’ undefeated.
- I might not even write that.
- [Laughing] Fa sho.
- Julio gonna take us all the way. I feel
like he gonna do it.
I’ll tweet that from my real account.
- From my real account for sure.
- Y'all go get that Madden 22 out now.
I ain't even coming out the house cuz I'm on Madden.
- Go check out Madden 22,
with some new music from yours truly
featuring Jack Harlow, "Ball is Life."
- What's goin’ on? It's Morray.
I am playing "Draft, Tweet or Burner"
with B/R Gridiron.
You know the vibes. We on there.